Elizabeth is with us in Texas hey
Elizabeth how are you I'm doing great
how are you today
better than I deserve what's up so I'm
looking for some advice to talk to my
church leadership about not getting the
paycheck protection program
loans to turn into a grant okay well
what type of what type of church is this
okay all right well I'm going to be
doing a video to send out to churches
early next week on this subject because
I'm telling small businesses not to do
it because it's a loan and it's the SBA
there's slow the forgiveness is likely
to be changed
it's triple don't do it for churches and
here's why you just let the federal
government into the management of your
organization and if you don't think that
there's a high probability that people
who do not agree with your theology in
Congress will tie the forgiveness of
that loan to you behaving in a
politically correct way than you're
naive you are about to get messed over
by your government
you're about to be forced to do things
that you're that you believe the Bible
tells you not to do in order to get the
forgiveness of this loan that is coming
it's not in the writing today but all
you've got to do is have a regime change
in the White House or all you've got to
do is have you know people with that
that believe things that you believe the
Bible doesn't say voted in to attach it
to the back of a bill you know like they
did attached crap to this bill but it'll
be okay then oh yeah we were gonna
forgive it but we won't forgive it
unless you go along with this social
view of this issue that I guarantee you
Southern Baptists wouldn't agree with
okay so you're about to get your church
into a mess that's my prediction please
don't do it I agree I hope they will
take your life if you're trying to have
one more secondary question I'm sure I
know for individuals you say through the
six months of expenses for an emergency
fine what would you recommend for
churches the same if you can build up to
it
it takes it's longer and it takes longer
to build retained earnings in an
organization a small business or a
church than it does in your personal
situation because the expenses are
higher for one thing but and there's
always something a ministry that that
needs to be funded instead of the
savings account being funded but
obviously a church I was with a group of
pastors this week and in the group there
were several of them that were debt-free
and had strong cash positions and they
were in a completely different headspace
than the the pastors that were in debt
and that didn't have cash right now and
and so yeah but yes sir I I again I any
good organization nonprofit for-profit
whatever needs to have retained earnings
or the equivalent of returning earnings
to survive that and and you know
Elizabeth back to the original part the
original question to let's keep in mind
the borrower is slave to the lender
you're a Southern Baptist Church in
Texas do you want to be under the
control of the Small Business
Administration the federal government
and a Congress who will institute
politically correct social programs that
violate your biblical beliefs you do not
want to be slave to that master that is
disastrous and today that is not part of
the forgiveness but there is nothing
stopping them from going oh well we're
gonna you know and we we were gonna
forgive it but we're not gonna forgive
it for those of you that are bigots
that's exactly what will happen by the
way Dave that won't require legislation
that'll require one person in the media
who's got enough of a bully pulpit to
say you
can't have federal funds keeping your
church doors open and practice
discrimination that's and they'll start
bringing up the phantom separation of
church and state and to your point
they'll padlock those doors so fast
it'll make your head spin well or
they'll call the loan when it won't be
forgiven they're holding the forgiveness
of the loan that's her over your head so
now two longer forgiven that's right now
you've just got a loan yeah and so
they're taking these things out with the
assumption it's going to be forgiven and
I'm telling you that forgiveness comes
at a price later so I can promise you
not saying the current president would
do that I'm not saying that certain
members of Congress or Senate would do
that but I know you do not want the
political whims and aspirations with
social agendas of Washington running
your dadgum Church that is just a
disastrous idea so please don't do that
I hope I wasn't unclear